bonjour christopher harmonie merci
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt
france alors on a parlé du danemark avec
ce corona parce qu'elle est la situation
tout simplement à la situation sanitaire
dans au danemark en ce moment la
situation est très bonne
très stable nous avons très peu de de
comptage et très peu de de spitz alizé
est environ 13 % de la population sont
passés les maintenant donc la situation
semble bien bonne et elle est danois ont
hâte à retourner à la vie normale
et cette idée de corona passeport est
une idée qui qui va être utilisé
maintenant pour revenir à la vie que
nous connaissons pour pouvoir visiter le
coiffeur ou pour pouvoir visiter le parc
amusement tivoli à coquelles
vous parliez tout à l'heure le nombre de
vaccinés 1 au danemark
comment justement a été organisé cette
campagne
de vaccination dans le pays elle est
plutôt lente mais nous avons commencé
avec les le plus gêné les groupes aussi
qui ont le plus de risques
ceux qui ont une autre maladie déjà et
au fur et à mesure nous sommes arrivés
au bout aux gens de l'âge de mes parents
qui ont environ à 75 ans et nous
continuerons au fur et à mesure au moins
est né et peut-être au mois de mai ce
sera mon tour d'être l'axé mais aussi
alors on parle bien sûr de ce corona
passe un passeport un vaccinale tous les
pays d'europe en parle la
grande-bretagne en a parlé aussi
récemment
souvent on voit des personnes qui ne
font pas forcément favorable à ce
passeport vaccinale c'était le cas en
grande-bretagne
est ce que c'est le cas aussi chez vous
ou au danemark oui mais je crois que
nous sommes un peuple un peu plus
pragmatique ya certains qui qui n'aime
pas l'idée de ce qu on n'a pas semé la
plupart ont envie de retourner à une vie
normal aussi vite que possible et donc
on accepte d'être testé et de montrer le
résultat de son test si on veut aller au
coiffeur ou au restaurant
comme pratiquement le monde entier le
danemark subi bien sûr cette crise du
coronavirus depuis un an maintenant
comment ça se passe chez vous au
danemark
quel est l'état de la population on a vu
à plusieurs manifestations tout à
l'heure notamment en italie contre
les mesures de les mesures sanitaires
est ce que c'est le cas aussi chez vous
au danemark
oui il ya eu des manifestations mais
elles ont été assez tranquille et bien
sûr les danois n'aime pas vivre sous ces
restrictions
mais il y accepte social qu'il faut se
tenir à distance les uns des autres et
rester dans les petits bouts qu'on
connaît et on peut s'amuser et dire que
que cette distance sociale fait quelque
chose de naturel pour un pays nordique
nous ne nous ne sommes pas être très
très proches les uns des autres donc
c'est plutôt facile de deux d'accepter
les règles on en parlait tout à l'heure
un la rouverture à des cafés des
restaurants est prévue pour le 21 avril
prochain
les coiffeurs c'est le sait le 6 avril
et puis vous parler aussi du parc
tripoli 1 à copenhague
est ce que justement la rouverture de
tous ces lieux le 6 et le 21 avril
vous paraît des bonnes dates vous paraît
cohérent par rapport à la stratégie du
pays oui c'est cohérent mais ça pourrait
peut-être aller un peu plus vite parce
que nos chiffres en ce qui concerne les
hospitalisés sont très bons et il semble
que la pandémie est sous contrôle
merci beaucoup christopher agonie
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes et ancien conseiller au
ministère danois des finances merci à
vous